donc les gens installés sur ce site ne
font pas du camping d'hiver par amour de
la nature mais par amour pour leurs
enfants
l'enjeu l'une des quarante places dans
une classe de maternelle à l'école
d'immersion française euros dans notre
dame de grâce tous les parents veulent
offrir ce qu'il ya de mieux à leurs
enfants ici pour cela qu'on fait ici
cette même chose sur les parents des
enfants qui vont la lancée nous top
cela fait une trentaine d'années que des
parents campent devant l'école robert
dans l'espoir d'y envoyer leurs enfants
sa réputation n'est plus à faire
l'inscription est ouverte à tous sans
égard au lieu de résidence
l'établissement offre des programmes
enrichi en mathématiques et en sciences
explique cette mère il y à différents
niveaux de cours de français et
d'anglais et même des études hébraïques
si cela vous intéresse
rovio n'est pas un cas unique à la
commission scolaire une bourriche 28 ans
les parents patientent devant au moins
quatre autres écoles anglophones
majoritairement situés dans l'ouest de
l'île à notre population à agrandir
chaque année et en chercher
les opportunités pour trouver les bons
place l'une des façons d'éviter la cohue
vers certaines écoles publiques à
vocation spécialisés et d'assurer que
toutes les écoles publiques soient plus
inclusive selon ce professeur permettent
aux plus grands nombres de réussir au
niveau au niveau scolaire mais d'avoir
aussi d'autres sortes d'activités qui
permettrait un enrichissement complet
des individus selon le sociologue
quatre élèves sur cinq qui ont fréquenté
une école publique internationale ou à
vocation spécialisés se rend au cégep
contre 2 élève sur cinq
s'ils sont diplômés d'une école
régulière ici valérie michaela bayne
radio canada montréal